こんにちは
Dr,はじめだ
♪～
《はじめ、昆虫ポケモン
目が二重でない時は
睡眠時間がしっかり確保できた証拠である。》
はい、というわけで今回は
マッチを準備しました。
何個頼んだんですかね
いやこれマジで何個だ
やべえ、ちょ、思ったより多いかも
あらららら
多くない？ちょ待って
あ～！
何個だ、
数えよう！
ひと箱に何本のマッチが入っているかだな
何本、何本だろう
・　・　・（♪～
・・・32、33、34
うわー適当だな
34ってどういうことだ
3つで約100本でしょ
１２個入りだ
3つで100本の、
1箱400×それが10個
4000本だ！
マッチ棒を4000本準備しました
俺は思ってしまった
マッチ棒はこうすると燃えますと
こうね
フッ
この火力、たまらん‼
いやたまるけど
マッチ棒4000本を一気に燃やすと
どれくらいの火力になるのかっていうのをちょっと実験しようと思います
怖ぁ！
て訳で今回はこちらに棒を準備しました
ブラシの先端にマッチ棒4000本をつけていきましょう
待ってこれめんどいわ
よし
ああ　いい感じいい感じ
こんな感じです。これを繰り返していきます
♪～
あのぉ　　1000個にしときましょう
ごめんなさい、1000個にしときます
多分これね、多分ね多分4000個でやったらちょっと嫌な予感がする
4000個でやったらもう多分爆発物になっちゃうんで
ちょっとすいません。1000個でいきましょう！
はい！こんな感じだ
ボンバーやないかい
はい、というわけで無事完成しました
4000は無理だ
家が吹き飛んでしまう
というわけでマッチ棒1000個つけました
こんな感じでございます
さぁ、問題はここからだ
このマッチ棒1000個をどうやって点火するかと言いますと
マッチを燃やす用の巨大なやすりを準備しました
このやすりを発火しなさそうな鏡とかにくっつけていきます
これ、こ、燃えるよね？
完璧だ
OK、OK、ばっちり
このやすりをこういう感じでちょっと貼っていきます
はい、というわけでこんな感じでございます
いやぁいいんじゃないんすかぁ？
はい、とういうわけで無事マッチ棒とやすりが完成しました
皆さん大変お待たせしました
マッチ棒1000本の火力、試してみましょう
よしいくぞいくぞ、行くぞお前らいくぞ
いきます
スリー！（3）
ツー！（2）
ワン！（1）
うわあああ　はぁいとぉ
家ではやりませーんよ！
♪～
あの実際炎が強いと危ないので一応水を準備しました
よしバッチリじゃないでしょうか
じゃあ早速点火してみましょう！
これがマッチ棒1000本の火力だ
では、いこう
♪～
ハァッッ！！　ｗ
やろやろ
まって凄いなんかミスりたくねぇわ
いくぞ！！
スリー！（3）
ツー！（2）
ワン！（1）
カッ　（点火）　うわあぁ！！！　×3
（スロー）
うわー、やばいやばいやばいｗｗｗｗ
うわ、すげぇ！すげぇｗｗ
ぇ結構燃えるんだね
えっへっへんｗｗちょっと待って
友）えぇースゴォイ！
2016年オリンピックはじめしゃちょーは応援します
♪～
一瞬凄かったよね
出だしがもうっ…バンッだったんで
いや、すごいね
これは4000本いけるんじゃないっすかぁ？ｗ
ちょっといけそうなんで、またチャレンジしようと思います
あのーちょっと危ないのでなるべくマネしないで下さい
もしどうしてもしたいっていう君
お父さん、お母さんと一緒にやりましょう
炎、なんだろ
花火してもいい場所とかね
花火とかしてもいい安全な場所でやってみて下さい！
うごぉお！ハッハッハッ！